(upbeat music)
- [Narrator] It's one
of the biggest lockdowns
China has imposed during the pandemic.
One that looks a lot like what happened
in Wuhan two years ago when
COVID-19 first emerged.
Since late December, 13 million people
in the city of Xi'an have
been ordered to stay home
as a Delta variant led to an outbreak
of more than 2000 cases,
a high number for China.
- They're not letting people
in or out of the city,
really taking just a
very aggressive approach.
- [Narrator] China has locked down
a number of cities during the pandemic,
and in early January
reported its first case
of the fast spreading Omicron variant
in the city of Tianjin.
But this time, what's happening and Xi'an
has sparked a nationwide outcry
online about food shortages.
Some stranded residents
said on social media
that they were down to their
last pack of instant noodles.
But the government says there
are enough food supplies,
and the lockdown is
Xi'an could also threaten
the global semiconductor shortage,
especially since the city is home
to some of the world's
biggest memory chip makers.
(speaking in foreign language)
The stakes are high as China
is about to host the Winter Olympics.
And the lockdown is Xi'an is
turning out to be a big test
for China's Zero-COVID Strategy.
So how strict is the lockdown in Xi'an?
When the rules first came into effect,
one person per household
was allowed to go out
once every two days to buy
food and other necessities.
But restrictions were
tightened after a few days,
with tens of thousands
send to quarantine centers,
and everyone else banned
from leaving their homes
except to get a COVID test,
similar to the rules
in Wuhan back in 2020.
- [Jonathan] Certainly a lot of people
are making the comparison
between Wuhan and Xi'an
and we've seen as in Wuhan two years ago,
we see stories coming out
through social media primarily
of families, households, people,
encountering pretty
difficult circumstances.
- [Narrator] The government
promised free delivery
of groceries to those stranded at home.
The many complained online saying
they received little to no supplies.
The #Xi'anGroceryShoppingIsDifficult,
was viewed more than 400 million times
on the Chinese social media
platform Weibo as of January 7th
and some say the
government hasn't provided
enough food since the lockdown began.
(gentle music)
(indistinct chatter)
There were also complaints about run-ins
with authorities enforcing the rules.
This video, which has been widely shared
since New Year's Eve, shows
a man being beaten by guards,
with comments saying that he had gone out
to buy steamed buns.
The owner of the video couldn't be reached
and it hasn't been independently verified.
The police acknowledged the
incident and said the two guards
had been punished with a seven
day detention and a $30 fine.
Hospitals have been also widely criticized
on social media for
not giving medical care
to some patients with
non COVID conditions.
For instance, a pregnant woman said
she was denied medical attention
because of an expired COVID test.
Authorities later said they
will loosen some requirements.
- But then, there are definitely people
who both within Xi'an and outside of Xi'an
are supportive of these measures.
People who look at the Chinese
government response and say,
"That was the right thing to do."
- [Narrator] The lockdown is Xi'an
could also exacerbate the global shortage
of semiconductors found in the
electronics we use every day.
Samsung and Micron are some
of the world's largest chip makers
and both have factories in Xi'an.
According to research from TrendForce
Samsung has two production
lines in the city
that make flash memory products,
used in devices such as
hard drives and cameras.
Samsung didn't give details,
but said it had to
temporarily adjust operations.
Micron said the city's
closure had some impact
on its output of chips,
but it was working with
officials to identify solutions.
- If they need to make an adjustment
to their Xi'an operations
that may mean that affects
some of their other chip
operations elsewhere.
We'll have to see how big
of a hit this will be.
- [Narrator] Just weeks
before China is set to host
the Winter Olympics in Beijing,
health authorities confirm
the first cases of Omicron
in the neighboring city of Tianjin.
And they ordered mass testing
for its 14 million residents.
- You have officials everywhere,
who are looking at Xi'an's example
and who are going to be hoping
that they are not subjected
to the same sort of scrutiny.
(speaking in foreign language)
- [Narrator] The winter Olympics
is set to begin on February 4th,
and China is allowing foreigners
to enter in large numbers
for the first time since
the pandemic began,
though under very strict rules,
to minimize contact with locals.
With cold temperatures
increasing transmissibility
and countries around the world
reporting hundreds of
thousands of daily cases,
keeping out COVID-19, is
becoming more challenging.
- China already is
feeling a lot of pressure
to really pull off these
Olympics and make them succeed.
There's obviously also a
lot of geopolitical pressure
on China right now and so,
I think the best answer
that they wanna have is to say,
"We pulled off a successful Olympic"
and part of that includes
containing COVID.
(people cheering)